These are magnetic microrobots,
just
millimeters in size.
They bend and move in response to applied magnetic fields
And with these magnetic fields
controlled by a gaming controller the
micro robots can be driven carefully and
precisely.
They can turn by changing the
direction of the magnetic field.
Roll in a rotating field
And even grasp and jump
It often feels like you're playing a
video game.
In some previous work I did
as a demonstration I was pushing blocks
of material around and using a micro robot
like a bulldozer.
And the demonstration I
did was playing Tetris.
The idea is this technique could be used
to assemble human organ tissues by
arranging blocks of different types of
cells in particular patterns.
The way these scientists actually fabricate the
micro robots is pretty ingenious.
Tiny rare earth magnets are magnetized in a
strong magnetic field.
Then they're mixed into a UV resin that will harden when
exposed to UV light.
The mixture is poured into a mold and placed on a stage
below which is a rotatable permanent magnet.
This creates an adjustable
magnetic field to which all the tiny
magnets in the resin align.
When the
desired orientation is reached UV light
cures the resin in one particular spot
locking those magnets in place.
Then the magnetic field can be adjusted and the
next section cured.
Ultimately the result is a flexible device with imbedded
magnets that have different orientations
depending on where they are.
This pattern of orientations is what
gives these micro robots their unique
behavior in response to magnetic fields.
If we can point multiple compass needles in opposite directions within a flexible
device,
if we apply the field vertically
those compass needles will both try to
orient and align with that applied field.
With the right magnetic fields the results can be pretty
sophisticated.
Watch this micro robot
pick up a block
and then roll with it over to a ramp.
It rolls up the ramp,
deposits the block at the top,
and then
returns to its original position.
The idea is that devices like this could be
used in medical applications.
So this could be sending a device into fluid
areas in your body or into your
gastrointestinal tract. For example a
capsule that you could swallow which
will go passively through your GI tract,
have no wires attached and at the right
moment we can activate a sampling
chamber basically to open up and take
samples of either stomach or small
intestine contents, take biopsy samples
of the intestinal wall.
But grippers like
these may not be the only magnetic
microrobots invading your body.
A different research group has pioneered
these even smaller peanut-shaped
magnetic particles.
And under the right magnetic field conditions they form
swarms.
This warm can take on different
configurations: the vortex, where many
particles travel together like a school of fish,
the chain, where particles line
up and travel single-file.
And the ribbon, where motion is perpendicular to the
line of particles.
One potential application of micro robotic swarms is
drug delivery.
Each magnetic particle
could carry a small amount of drug and
be guided toward the intended drug delivery site.
So to make a swarm useful
for essential biomedical applications, you'd
like to keep the swarm aggregated.
You probably will not be able to see single
micrometer sized particles but you could
see the entire swarm.
So you'd like to keep it aggregated so you can move it
and keep track.
But then going through
tight environments, for example going
through blood vessels
if your swarm, the overall swarm size is bigger than the
blood vessel then it doesn't fit so you
need to line them up and squeeze through
so that's the motivation for being able
to control the shape of the swarm.
And, who knows, one day you might have swarms
of magnetic microrobots cleaning your
teeth.
another group of researchers has used
tiny magnetic robots to clear biofilms -
those are communities of bacteria and
the protective sugar polymers around them.
They typically build up on medical
devices, the insides of pipes, and on teeth.
Can I ask, does this idea of
magnetic control of micro robots, does it
supplant previous concepts?
Like I'm trying to conceptualize this in terms of
like you know sci-fi futures with
nanobots where I imagine you know we
imagine these things as really
self-contained and you know powering
themselves around the body and that sort
of stuff.
Yeah, great question. So the advantage of
magnetic fields is that it's a very
scalable technique. So we can make
magnetic microbots that are single cell
size and we can make them that are
centimeters in size and the principles
behave similarly.
It pulls off a lot of
the functionality to
off-board magnetic coils. We can have a big
computer sitting there and power supply
It's a lot of the hard aspects of
driving a robot we can do as
traditional size. You can have a big computer
We can have medical imaging hooked up
and do all these things off board and
then on board we're just transmitting
the magnetic field directly to the
device and so this our micro robot is
basically then just like the mechanical
hand of the robot and the rest of the
robot is really sitting on the table
beside the patient.
Hey this episode of
Veritasium is supported by viewers like
you on Patreon and by Audible. There's no
better place to listen. Listening makes
us smarter, more connected people. And
there's no better time to start
listening than right now with a 30-day
trial and your first audiobook plus two
Audible originals free when you go to
audible.com slash veritasium or text
veritasium that's V E R I T A S I U M
to 500 500. Now if you're looking for
something good to listen to might I
recommend "How to Change Your Mind: What
the new science of psychedelics teaches
us about consciousness dying, addiction
depression and transcendence by Michael
Pollan. This is a fascinating book and
it's narrated by the author himself. I'm
actually listening to it at the moment
and he may be changing my mind about the
very nature of consciousness. What I find
so incredible is how recent this
scientific field is and what it's
revealing about how all of our brains work.
Now when I'm listening to books
like this I actually look forward to
getting stuck in traffic.
I find it reduces my stress levels
because I'm learning something rather
than just wasting time in the car.
Now the way it works with Audible is that as
a member you can choose three titles
each month: one audiobook and two Audible
originals that you can't hear anywhere
else. And if you don't like a book you
can exchange it no questions asked and
the books you get are yours to keep. You
can go back and re-listen anytime even
if you cancel your membership. Just go to
A U D I B L E dot com slash veritasium or text
veritasium to five hundred five hundred
and browse their unmatched selection of
audio content. So I want to thank Audible
for supporting me and I want to thank
you for watching.